so tonight is your night congratulations
on this big award what does it mean to
be honored in this way especially having
Leo give you the award very cool well
I'm honored and I monitored Leo's giving
it to me
what else could I say I'm on it that's
great do you have a favorite role that
you've ever done one that stands out to
you that you love and one that you hate
I do but I don't want to say it okay
what's the favorite then well I mean
even Irishman I like I feel good about
when you have had the storied and
incredible career is there more to do
you know when the Irish man came out I
was like he's still like you should be
on your yacht in the South of France
like not you know like they're still do
you still have big dreams friends still
working so hard I am what else am I
going to do at this point and when
people hear your name it's synonymous
with just an iconic actor what do you
hope that just your legacy in the art
that you've put out into the world means
to all these other up and comers well I
hope I hope it's positive and that they
get things from it from what I've given
off that have a positive have a positive
meaning and can be a good example
especially these days even you know the
political stuff at all I don't even like
to call it political because it's not
political it's life it's it's the world
it's not about politics I'm not a
politician and I'm not it but we're in a
you know in this kind of situation
unfortunately and tell me about your
friendship with Leo Leo I've known Leo
since he was 15 we did this boy's life
and so I mean if you think about us what
is it
it's 40 he's 45 so that's 30 30 years
I've known right yeah a long time he's
growing up he certainly has grown up we
love him congratulations to you et at
the SAG Awards with Life Achievement a
winner mr. DeNiro an icon
[Music]